hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
this was Google in 1998 so we're right
between that house
and this house
renting this
half of the house
ping pong table
here
going to the Legislative Office
there's Larry
CEO of Google
say something
hi
it was a small company run out of the
garage of Susan wojcicki who is
interestingly the current CEO of YouTube
simply from recognizing the value of
organizing information on the web Google
managed to grow from a few tinkering PhD
students to a formidable giant that now
owns over 90 percent of search
and carries out over 8 billion search
queries per day
for two decades now Google has been the
Undisputed king of web searches the term
Google has been synonymous with
searching for information need a recipe
or remove your review or just settling
an argument with a friend you can just
Google it
with a net worth of 1.15 trillion
dollars in 2022 they seem Unstoppable so
what exactly could make a massive
company like Google Panic so much so
that they issued an internal Code Red
well it's open ai's chat GPT of course
with Microsoft's plans to integrate the
AI system into their search engine Bing
Google search May face a serious threat
for the first time in its history
could this be one of the biggest
technology story arcs in history while
making this episode I kind of felt like
we're at the beginning of an AI War
so in the following we'll learn what
Google might do about the situation
they're actually already fighting back
we'll get into that and we'll also see
why exactly chat GPT is such a threat to
Google's Central business model let's
take a look
Fusion TV
[Music]
when to transform just about every
industry including education chat GPT
pass the US medical licensing exam the
bar exam and got a B on a Wharton MBA
paper
a conversational chatbot capable of
responding to any query in a human-like
manner always seem to be a technology of
the future for the masses anyway until
chat GPT
following its release chat GPT has
garnered huge attention from around the
world
to give you an idea of the scale of this
moment chat GPT has been the fastest app
in history to reach 100 million users
it's taken just two months whereas
tiktok took nine and Instagram 30.
a rapid adoption rate is a classic early
signal of a disruptive product or
technology
a couple of months ago we took a deep
dive into chat GPT since then it's been
updated and is better than ever
however as I previously stated it's
important to know that it's not perfect
and may sometimes give bias or outright
incorrect information if you want to see
that episode on chat GPT and open ai's
views on the future of these systems in
more detail the link for that episode
can be found in the description below
[Music]
Microsoft is looking to capitalize
namely by putting this technology in
their search engine Bing the massive
implications of this will be discussed
later in the episode but for now we've
got to find out something how did
Microsoft and openai get involved with
each other in the first place
the alliance between the two started in
2019 when Microsoft invested one billion
dollars into openai this was very
crucial for both companies open AI
needed some cash as well as the
computing power of Microsoft's Azure
cloud services this allowed the AI
research firm to scale and drastically
reduce its operating costs Microsoft on
the other hand was able to acquire open
ai's intellectual property portfolio in
the process
in essence Microsoft now has access to
some of the world's best AI technology
giving it a Competitive Edge over other
major players in the tech industry since
then Microsoft and openai have been
working together on various projects and
specifically chat GPT CEO saty Nadella
saying its impact will be quote at the
magnitude of the personal computer the
internet mobile devices and the cloud
[Music]
when Microsoft made the bombshell
announcement that they were integrating
chat GPT into Bing Google was in shock
an emergency code red situation was
declared and I could imagine the Frantic
meetings one Google executive told the
New York Times it was a make or break
moment for the company
but wait this is Google we're talking
about the company with Far and Away the
world's leading search engine they
dominate 90 of search queries Microsoft
with their dinky little Bing accounts
for only nine percent of worldwide
desktop searches in 2022
so why is Google panicking Google is
looking at what might happen in the
future and not what's happening today
chat Bots are not new but the level of
performance seen by chat GPT definitely
is the thing that sets it apart from the
Medicore chat bots of the past is that
it's a generative pre-trained
Transformer or GPT in plain language it
just means that it's been trained on
billions of parameters and petabytes of
text this training allows the system to
generate new text in a way that mimics
the understanding of a wide range of
queries and can respond accordingly
chat GPT or the inevitable flood of AI
assistance has the potential to
revolutionize how we interact with
search engines
Microsoft could see this as well and
that's why they've been betting on open
Ai and its technology
for a second I just want you to stop and
think about it if an ai-powered search
engine gave you the specific information
or answer you want in a concise manner
but you could also ask further questions
and drill down into the details that you
want this would be revolutionary you
don't have to click through a bunch of
links and waste your time right now if
you want a specific answer you have to
Google what you're looking for get a
bunch of results that may or may not fit
and if it's specific enough you end up
going to a forum anyway and searching
through all the answers there in this
ai-powered search engine world the
answer would already be synthesized for
you and this is because the AI has
already crawled through the whole web
and read it already and I think this is
where ai-powered search will excel the
most for very specific problems just
this implication alone is huge obviously
if you want to know something political
or something that could have a slant or
bias that's another story
uh it has Google shook a little bit uh
calling a code red and there's a good
reason for that chat GPT is potentially
an existential threat to Google's
business because Google relies 60 of its
revenue on search and chat GPT offers an
alternative to search which is a
One-Stop question answering shop powered
by AI but this could change the game of
search entirely which is core to
Google's business
if open AI integrates a chat gpt-like
language model into Bing search engine
people will just be able to find the
results that they need without having to
scroll through a flat page of search
results that are littered with ads this
may be good news for users but for a
company like Google it's very bad news
and why is this so bad for Google
because roughly 60 percent of their
revenue comes from Google Search
if the magnitude of this income becomes
significantly damaged it could be
catastrophic
Google's business model is centered
around advertising it's been their
long-standing primary source of Revenue
by charging companies for promoted
search links or AdSense links on
websites the company has built a
lucrative business model
but it's clear that chat gpt's
integration with Bing has the potential
to disrupt this entire system
if that doesn't sound bad enough the
creator of Gmail himself said that chat
GPT will destroy Google's business in
two years
while I don't think this is the case
because Google isn't going to just sit
still as you'll soon see it still is
interesting that he said this
in January of 2023 the Department of
Justice filed an Anti-Trust lawsuit
against Google
they stated quote Google has used
anti-competitive exclusionary and
unlawful means to eliminate or severely
diminish any threats to its dominance
over digital advertising Technologies
this isn't to mention the 12 000 Google
employees that were recently let go this
is probably due to higher interest rates
and a changing Market but still all
things considered these are some of the
biggest challenges Google has seen in
its 20 years of dominance so it's no
surprise that the company issued the
code red but here's the crazy thing they
even sought help from their co-founders
Larry Page and Sergey Brin both of which
had stepped down from their executive
positions back in 2019 and have not been
actively involved in the company's
operations according to the New York
Times the pair was invited to an
executive meeting to strategize on how
to integrate chatbot features into
Google search engine they were also said
to be devising a plan for the company's
AI operations
according to Forbes Sergey Brin has
requested access into Google's internal
code and he was taking a look at some
Lambda code this could indicate that
Google will be using Lambda in their
response to open AI
when Google calls them the Old Guard you
know things are getting serious
meanwhile Microsoft is going all out
they're going to be investing an extra
10 billion dollars into open AI
as part of the new agreement Microsoft
will receive 75 percent of open AI
profits until it recoups its investment
and then will hold a 49 stake in the
company afterwards unfortunately this is
the antithesis of what the open AI
company originally stood for
if all goes well this may turn out to be
one of the best business deals of the
decade
right now Chrome is the default option
for Android and Google pays Apple huge
sums of money just to be the default
option on iPhones and Mac OS devices
this has no doubt worked wonders for
Google in the past especially since
there's been no real alternative but now
that Ben could eat some market share I
think Google will use their default
status and dominating market share to
their advantage while they hit back
this is how I think things may play out
if Google gets their act together
so Google are probably going to rapidly
prototype and release an ai-powered
search engine competitor integrated into
Google Chrome and because Google Chrome
is the default browser for so many this
new tool will gain widespread adoption
without much effort and end up killing
being AI before it really gets a chance
to start
now I could be wrong but it just seems
like Google has to make a major move
like this
it's reported that Google is working on
20 AI projects including image
generation tools a product for Prototype
app testing and even a green screen mode
for YouTube creatives
one of the most interesting pieces of
research is music LM an AI that can
transform whistled or humming Melodies
into a certain style which is described
in text
so it's clear that Google isn't sleeping
in a staff memo CEO Sundar pachai wrote
quote I am confident about the huge
opportunity in front of us thanks to the
strength of our mission the value of our
products and services and our early
investments in AI to fully capture it
we'll have to make some tough choices
and I think that last sentence is key it
seems like Google may be forced to put
the safety issues on the back seat and
will just start unleashing the AI
products they could turn the playing
field around quite quickly
and this is some news just in according
to CNBC Google is currently testing a
chat GPT competitor called Apprentice
Bard internally with its employees and
also a group of Engineers have left open
Ai and started their own AI company and
the first product Claude is similar to
chat GPT but better in some cases the
company called anthropic AI has already
raised over one billion dollars and
guess what Google just invested 300
million
things are really heating up now
but for those of you who are really into
technology something doesn't add up here
Google has been working on AI technology
for a long time even as far back as 2016
Google CEO Sundar pachai wanted to make
Google quote an AI first company so how
could they be caught with their pants
down like this
well in a Twist of irony Google
inadvertently gave open AI the keys to
the castle
[Music]
in 2017 Google researchers published a
paper that would silently change the
world it outlined a method of processing
text images and more it was called a
Transformer and their technique allowed
an AI to focus on specific parts of an
input rather than having to process the
entire sequence this allows for more
effective and efficient processing of
language data
so in a way it was this groundbreaking
work from Google scientists that later
led to the development of open ai's chat
GPT
problem for Google is that they moved
too slowly and this was due to safety
concerns and rightly so
such a large company has a lofty
reputation an offensive or misleading AI
would be of high reputational risk for
Google in general even though AI
language models feel very human-like
they occasionally produce a logical or
outright false information and due to
these reasons Google has released
nothing publicly but the unavoidable
consequence was frustrated researchers
so some of them have left to raise money
for their own AI startups
that being said Google does have several
language models for internal use the
most famous of which was Lambda this
language model made headlines in June of
2022 when a former Google engineer
claimed it was sentient while that may
not be true it was certainly
sophisticated
[Music]
so let's wrap this episode up by taking
a look at what we know so far about an
ai-powered Microsoft search engine
Microsoft is expected to launch Bing
with some chat GPT features at the end
of March
there is still some growing speculation
about how the AI system will be
integrated into the search engine
one possibility is that chat GPT could
allow users to just communicate with
Bing in a more human-like way you don't
have to worry about keywords you just
ask Bing the question in the same way
that you would ask another person an
anonymous Microsoft source told
Bloomberg that more conversational and
contextual responses to queries will win
over users by providing better quality
answers that go beyond links Bing is
about to get the features of Dali 2.
that text to image generator that caused
such a stir and kicked off this latest
wave of AI art
this integration will allow users to
type in text and generate images this
feature will be particularly beneficial
for searches where images don't
currently exist essentially it will
allow users to create new images on
demand Microsoft has said that they're
working closely with open AI so this
feature doesn't generate explicit or
inappropriate visuals
so it looks like Bing is getting a major
overhaul with chat GPT and Dali 2
features integrated it sure is going to
grab everyone's attention when it's
launched how exactly this pans out Still
Remains to be seen but I certainly am
intrigued and will be interesting to see
how this plays out
so we may be on the cusp of a new era in
which the search engine that we know
becomes a thing of the past the digital
directories of old will become the
digital assistants of the future so I'm
going to make it clear Google Search
isn't going anywhere anytime soon but
it's so interesting to think that there
could be a legitimate Contender around
the corner and from Microsoft Bing of
all places just think a year or two ago
no one would have seen this coming it's
just amazing how fast things are moving
so what are your thoughts a link based
search result is going to expire do you
think you're going to warm up to an AI
bot serving you the information that you
need well Bing become a verb and finally
do you think Google will hit back faster
than we all expect
please let me know in the comments
section it's going to be an interesting
discussion
alright so that's about it from me feel
free to have a browse through the cold
fusion Channel there's plenty of
interesting topics on AI technology
business and much more
and also don't forget to check out the
chat GPT video linked below so thanks
for watching my name is the gogo and
you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll catch you again soon for the next
episode I'm going to play you out with a
new track I made over on the second
Channel
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
it's me thinking